flashing the three-finger hunger games
salute
hong kongers using the same symbol as
fellow democracy campaigners in thailand
and myanmar
this is one of the biggest protest
gatherings seen in hong kong in many
months
the crowds are here to support some of
the city's best-known activists
brought to court on charges of
subversion
they sacrificed their future for hong
kong and maybe this is the last chance
to see them
or say goodbye that's why it means so
much to me
the activists alleged crime
organizing an informal primary election
last year
the hope was to select pro-democracy
candidates
to run for legislative council elections
a routine matter in much of the world
but it took place shortly after the
national security law took effect
and for china's rulers it was a threat
one they say was manipulated from abroad
a small number of countries are
vilifying china by spreading lies about
territories including hong kong
they're up to their usual tricks of
politicizing and weaponizing human
rights issues
to interfere in other countries internal
affairs
and we will resist this
the activists taken to court in these
vans today face up to life in prison if
convicted 47 individuals were being
charged today
the chinese and hong kong authorities
promised that the national security law
would be used in a very narrow sense
it's clear that that is no longer being
the case and that's deeply concerning to
us so that's why we're here with a
number of other
foreign consulates the international
community can
see the resolve of the hong kong people
we want the judges to be fair to be
independent
and to be objective and give them a fair
trial
activists are concerned that the court
could be pressured to impose severe
sentences
in a bid to [ __ ] the democracy
movement once and for
all hoping for international support
they say hong kong's last freedoms are
at stake
[Music]
well dwp kong is on the ground there at
the courthouse
joins me phoebe what's the latest
well i have been standing staying here
outside the courtroom in hong kong
throughout the day so hundreds of people
show up today to uh at the court and
on the streets outside the court
courtroom to show support to the
opposition takers
uh prosecuted and a facing hearing
inside the court right next to me so um
they chant slogans such as
uh released political uh criminals and
uh all the protest demands uh slogans uh
throughout the day
and so um they want to show support and
by
uh being present here so they feel that
this is the few remaining ways that they
can protest and express their opinions
and um the situation has descended into
a little bit chaos
throughout the day as police uh accuse
the uh
public the crowd of endangered national
security or even
breaching the national security law
because they chant
the so-called subversive political
slogans which is now banned
in hong kong um so now the queue is
cleared and the crowd is
disbursed as police side sighted ronal
virus restrictions rules and uh
we know but the hearing is still going
on um
you said the hearing is still going on
what could be
the consequences of that hearing
well today is the first day of the
hearing of the
mass prosecution of the 47 opposition
figures
the court is handling the bail
application
and the legal procedures of the case so
the actual
hearing of the case uh hasn't begun
hasn't begun yet and
uh we will not expect we're expecting
more details as the hearing goes on
and uh about speaking about the the the
consequences of the convection so if
order if the opposition figures were
convicted
under the national security law they
could face life imprisonment which is a
very heavy sentence
um under the new law and it's also very
unlikely for them to be grounded bail
right before the hearing so that means
they could be detained
until the hearing finished
phoebe we've seen some support there
international support in our report
do you think there is enough
international support
well yesterday i also i met some of the
uh coastler staff
from the western countries here outside
the courts they
sent representatives um to uh to
to attend the hearings so um it also
showed the uh
how concerning this case to the
international community that
statements have been issued including
the us the european
uh union and also the uk so in the past
many prominent activists are lobby
support for the international community
but now
hong kong is expect more from the
western countries
particularly that statements are not
enough they hope for
more actions phoebe kong in hong kong
thank you
you